watch curly sue actress Allison Porter  deliver a flawless audition on the voice  that brought one coach to tears  remember this girl he's gonna cry well  she's all grown up now and left the  coach is absolutely stunned after her  audition on Monday night's season  premiere of The Voice  the 34 year old received a standing  ovation from all four coaches who  showered her with tons of praise and  compliments but it was Christina  Aguilera who was particularly touched  after hearing Alison's life story Ashley  got sober almost eight years ago and  I found love and I had children and that  was my my goal to just be a good mom and  I really feel like the universe just how  to plan for me because you guys turn for  me today and move by your story nobody  works harder than a mom between your  story and those pipes of yours I want to  be a part of your history not  surprisingly Alison went with team  Christina she has totally changed my  world